hello freak [ __ ] camouflage right I'm
not hunting yeah Under Armour makes a
lot of hunting gear Oh does it have to
know that they started making a start
they did not have me to be the face of
that campaign I can't imagine what it
would be if you wanted to try a new
career really always looking for women
to get involved in hunting oh really
yeah that's like a big thing like pretty
girls yeah hunting is that like is that
sexy um I think some people think it is
what what it is is unusual yeah see
these girls with full makeup on with
like really well applied camo on their
face so it's kind of obvious and then
they have like a dead lion next to them
and then they take these Facebook photos
and it gets really weird like there was
a girl she was pretty famous for it
because she was a cheerleader in Texas
mm-hmm and she shot a lion and only
renewed your vase and all these people
went crazy are attacking her and yeah
and it became the kendall Jenner I think
of her man and that that's what miss
Kardashian that's my right you might no
way there's no way not Jenna kendall
something I mean that's the most
endearing thing you ever done what's
that Kendall Jones Jones oh not a bar
not far pretty close yeah yeah I'm so
out of the loop mm-hmm someone's trying
to be oriental Kardashian loop I'd be
concerned which one's the one that had
the there it is there's a girl with the
lion like see so there's something
there's something weird about like this
picture right here look at this I don't
want to like that oh just take a look no
I'm sad but it's a DAB it'll ruin like
my week ash you'll be fun my whooping
campus can't sexy pose with a bow yeah
in a dead lion yeah I can't look at it
and by the way that lion is you know
it's lines all but there's a weird thing
about the hunting lion thing too because
a lot of them they're in these high
fence places where they go in these
lines are kind of trapped in the areas
yeah and sometimes they actually release
the line the day of the hunt
so this lion had been in a cage and then
release the line and this woman goes out
and shoots I mean I don't know if that
was the case with her yeah person who
every and sometimes yeah we'll go out
and shoot the line the line literally
has no idea what's going on it's not
even a free range line yes so to me
that's a mentally ill person but my
question for you
who is that is there something
primordial about because I think you
know we are I think inherently and this
is going to sound wrong it's going to
sound like feminist whatever but like
there's a lot of evidence that were
matriarchal species not that women
should have more power but that we're
sort of designed just like orca whales
Lions like female lions do all the
hunting and the men just it's not
economical for their energy because
they're so big you're hunting they'd
have to kill twice as much food right
there for protection
yeah and so and [ __ ] and whatever so
is there something some sort of
reptilian attraction to seeing a woman
go hunt food even though it's ironically
a lion you know no I don't think so I
don't like watching a woman cook watch a
woman cook it's probably sexy but is
locking them hunt is the same thing I
don't I don't think so yeah but maybe
it's just maybe it varies I think it's
more in lines of watching a woman cage
fight like there's some really pretty
women there right now that's because I'm
always sort of in this thing and people
always tell me like I have alpha vibe
and that's not sexy to men or it is or
is it case-by-case or is it the
generalization I'm just always
interested well I think what you are is
powerful and that's what's scary to
people that are insecure you're you're a
go-getter you're constantly doing things
and you're cut like I would imagine that
a guy who doesn't test himself or a
person who's not accomplished would be
very insecure around someone who's like
got more more ambition and more Drive
and more irons in the fire than they do
so they would feel insignificant like I
got it because my engine is insecurity
I'm pretty ironic yeah that's what fuels
the farm but if you were secure would
you be as ambitious or would you be
exactly the same I don't know if I can
even entertain a hypothetical because
the idea of being secure so far what if
someone came out with a security pill
yep and you took that all the way
no they heard they have that yeah that's
a chatterbox pills yeah yeah that's true
that's so let's start a business from
190 right it's like a people business
I'm telling you man we need to go into
business together I've got a good idea
ya know I heard there's a co-op that
when working with new vitamin company
branding out of China branding yeah you
did an amazing job with your brand with
yeah well I would say thank you sell my
brand is amazing I even heard this one
refer to you as your brand yes that is
but that's such a bizarre way of putting
things you know it's it's got such a
pejorative weird but we're comics so we
have an allergy to anything corny like
we can until say with like we can say it
but we have to do it with like an eye
roll like you have a very strong brand
but but part of your brand is not being
the guy who goes Moo marooned part of my
brain is not having a brand yeah but
yeah you do have one I guess incredibly
strong clear one that anybody could you
know like say in one sentence but part
of it is because you're so authentic and
anti like you know conscientious
calculated marketing that the word is an
Optima to your brand well that's like
that's one of the big issues in the
quote-unquote hunting community about a
lot of these girls that are involved in
this this hunting like you don't know so
I'm going to explain it to you yeah
there's this whole movement where these
pretty girls have I mean maybe some of
them are I mean for sure some of them
are authentic I don't want to yes credit
the ones that are authentic but a lot of
them are saying let me because I really
want to understand the and this is maybe
a generalization about men and women but
do you think women have the DNA and the
true rewards that are they getting
dopamine from hunt
are they inherent hunters the same way
women like playing sports yeah they
would love hunting interesting yeah
there was the same way people like very
challenging and difficult things that
offer you a massive reward we not do it
but sports is there's teamwork which is
a gives us dopamine and adrenaline you
know cuz I'm sort of interested in women
in general that do things like make out
with other guys when they're not
lesbians just to get another guy's
attention make up with other girls I'm
sorry what I say yes make up with other
girls right out of other girls like our
women hunting because they want to or
because
they feel socially part I think there's
both I mean I think we would obviously
make a massive generalization yeah we
said women do this because I hate that
yeah I hate when people say the left
does this or the right does that or men
do this in it it gets goofy yeah I could
never met someone that does it so I have
known I know a lot of them women they do
a lot of them yeah and some of them are
unquestionably authentic but some of
them are unquestionably targeting social
media and the specific avenues of
getting famous and making a living and
inside the hunting community it's a very
hotly debated subject about like whether
or not some of these women are legit and
who is legit and who's like verily and
what if their knowledge it does it
matter or no together why is it
different than a girl is a fitness freak
yeah you know a girl just like doing
that walk whatever is I mean we're
designed to keep if we get attention for
something our brain just keep doing it
was a vice thing about that today that i
retweeted that about thirsty pictures
yeah you mean integrals girls like with
bras on them like why do they do that
why are they they're getting like yeah
why do they have their ass hanging out
with a dong with their you know the legs
like sort of exposed in bed where
they're pretending that they're sleeping
and why are millions people looking at
them yeah cuz we like it you know and
yeah I mean what got us attention is
what we're going to keep doing
[Music]